[Musique]
addis abeba qui signifie nouvelles
fleurs en amharique est en train
d'éclore
la capitale éthiopienne vibre au son de
marteau piqueur les multiples grues sont
signe du boom immobilier qui
transforment le paysage urbain avec une
croissance économique de 8% par année
depuis dix ans le pays revient de loin
il leur a connu de grandes famines dans
les années 80 la dictature sanglant
demain je sois al-ahmar et âme pendant
vingt ans il a été chassé par l'ancien
premier ministre mêlés zenawi en 1991 en
2019 le pays espère entrer dans l'ère
industrielle et le mot démocratie est
sur toutes les lèvres
une femme présidente qu'est-ce qu'on a
besoin de plus on se dit que le travail
ne fait que commencer
c'est la nouvelle présidente d'ethiopie
salé ou à gaza au des entre dans
l'histoire comme première chef d'état du
pays
elle a été désignée à l'unanimité par
les parlementaires éthiopien d'emblée
elle parle de l'importance des femmes
dans son premier discours le
développement du pays passe désormais
par elle dit elle nous l'avons rencontré
au palais présidentiel gens vendent le
président cet entretien le combat qui
mérite d'être mené plus tôt
c'est celui contre la pauvreté si on
constatait pour qu'il y ait une égalité
en fin c'est un combat contre la
pauvreté parce que ceux qui souffrent le
plus de cette situation sont les femmes
et les enfants restant de ma vie
cette nomination arrive au moment où le
nouveau premier ministre impose la
parité dans son gouvernement les
ministères de la défense de la justice
du commerce du transport sont tous des
portefeuilles détenus par des femmes une
première sur le continent pour qu est-ce
qu on ne sait pas remplacer les hommes
c'est de travailler avec les hommes et
d'avoir notre part à la table du
gouvernement aussi pour que l'on puisse
apporter une perspective qui pourrait
être différente ce que l'on pourrait
apporter
[Musique]
diplomate de carrière elle a représenté
l'ethiopie entre autres au sénégal et en
france
son rôle pour le moment symbolique lance
un message clair les femmes ont leur
place dans les plus hautes sphères de
décision et elles l'apprennent grâce aux
investissements que de la chine
messieurs pea commun pu progresser
textuellement et rédactrice en chef du
journal économique le capital si vous
voyez les chiffres ya une vingtaine
d'années la situation de l'équipe était
était vraiment précaire c'était le
troisième pays au monde le plus pauvre
aujourd'hui nous nous trouvons dans une
situation où c'est vraiment l'un des
pays au monde qui a une très très forte
croissance du produit intérieur brut
[Musique]
celui qui est à la tête du gouvernement
s'est habillé remède la nouvelle
coqueluche du continent à 42 ans est le
plus jeune dirigeant en afrique
à peine arrivé au pouvoir et libère tous
les journalistes et les prisonniers
politiques
il fait également appel aux exilés
éthiopiens qui se trouve dans la
diaspora
[Musique]
son mot d'ordre madame mal qui veut dire
rassembler et non diviser pour mieux
régner
il applique à la lettre sa devise et va
à la rencontre de l'ennemi juré du pays
le président érythréen issaias afeworki
en quelques jours il met fin à 20 ans de
guerre avec l'erythrée voulu qu'on voit
depuis quelques mois sont des réformes
des changements
qui donne espoir emmanuel et gilles
houde sont d'anciens militants qui ont
lutté pour la démocratie en ethiopie
pascal volonté une volonté de changer
mais qu'il faudra bien évidemment rendre
durable en institutionnalisant la
plupart de ces rares envie de dire que
c'est une véritable révolution qui se
passe dans ce pays je dirais que c'est
plutôt un grand nettoyage de printemps
c'est à dire que on a chamboulé pas mal
de choses mais les problèmes qui
existent dans ce pays depuis 30 ans ils
sont là on s'y est pas attaquer car les
défis sont grands les tensions
inter-ethniques surtout dans le sud
menace l'intégrité même du pays
comment organiser des élections
parlementaires dans un pays où il ya 3
millions de déplacés comment recenser la
population d'un pays qui est déchiré par
des conflits interethniques
il ya quelques mois des élections ces
tensions se transporte sur les réseaux
sociaux pour cette jeune militante
il faut rester vigilant
les élections sont prévues en 2020 le
pays est à la croisée des chemins avec
ses 105 millions d'habitants et ses 80
groupes ethniques
le défi du gouvernement est d'assurer
une cohésion nationale tout en
garantissant la démocratie et la liberté
d'expression je crois que ce souffle aux
nouveaux cas a porté le premier ministre
nous aidons nous aller de l'avant aller
de l'avant en se souvenant du passé il
faut voir d'où nous venons pour
apprécier le présent on a vu le fond de
la bible
[Musique]